[Applause]
welcome my name is Jim Levinson and I'm
the director of Yale's Jackson Institute
for Global Affairs soon to become I'm
delighted to note Yale's Jackson school
of global affairs one of the wonderful
programs that Jackson oversees is the
Kerry initiative the initiative has four
components there's the Kerry seminar a
semester-long class taught by Professor
Kerry there Kerry fellows a team of Yale
students who work with secretary Kerry
on his research and writings there are
Kerry conversations one-on-one
conversations between secretary Kerry
and his guests and there's the Kerry
conference today is the second edition
of the annual Kerry conference the first
was focused on climate policy and this
year were looking at challenges to
democracy at home and abroad the
conference brings together the entire
Yale community highlighting the
interconnectedness that contributes to
what it means to be here at Yale we'll
start the conference with the session on
the military perspective on the
importance of American leadership in
defending democracy later this afternoon
Georgia gubernatorial candidate Stacey
Abrams will speak on defending democracy
at home and that will be in Woolsey Hall
tomorrow secretary Kerry will moderate a
discussion with three count'em three
fellow former secretaries of state
secretaries Madeleine Albright
Condoleezza Rice and Hillary Clinton
that'll be followed by panels of first
distinguished members of the press to
talk about the critical role of the
press in defending democracy and then a
panel on historical perspectives I'll
turn it over to secretary Kerry who will
introduce his panel of three former
secretaries of defense please join me in
welcoming Yale class of 66 and I might
add the 68th Secretary of State
Secretary John Kerry
[Applause]
welcome everybody thank you very much
Jim and congratulations on the
transformation that is going to take
place to the school which I might add I
think is long overdue and most
appropriate so we're living in a time
when a lot of people are wondering about
people to charge you make bad decisions
that lead to a terrible record and I'm
not going to talk about the Red Sox here
today at all folks but I want to thank
the many people who've had a lot to do
with helping to bring this conference
together and we are I just want to take
a few minutes to set the stage for the
next 48 hours here because we are living
in a time when democracies are
challenged and they're challenged at
home and abroad
it is unique we were talking in lunch
with the Secretary of Defense about how
strange it is that we're at a point
where we are worried about our own
democracy here at home and there were a
lot of questions some of which are very
unsettling about where we find ourselves
we obviously should never shy away from
those questions and there's nothing I
want to emphasize this
there's nothing preordained about
America's democracy other than the goals
that the founding fathers set out in the
vision that we have tried to live but
the actual democracy is not on automatic
pilot it doesn't work that way democracy
doesn't work that way so there's nothing
preordained about where we are headed
and history is full of examples of
democracies that failed so one thing is
clear we cannot take our own democracy
for granted we have to ask what we can
do to make it stronger now personally I
think our democracy can be stronger
when we ask ourselves why of two hundred
and forty five point five million
Americans aged 18 years and older in
November of 2016 only one hundred and
fifty-seven point six million were
registered to vote and only 138 million
actually voted leaving the world's
oldest democracy ranked 26th in voter
participation among that's that's just
six places from rock bottom among 32
osed countries I know that democracy
overseas can be stronger if we are sober
and serious and asking why after the
democratic surge post Cold War and after
the Arab Spring we are now seeing a
democratic recession in places from
Turkey to Egypt to the erosion of
democratic freedoms in Hungary
repressive regimes in the Philippines
surging to surprising victories on the
back of neo populism and liberal
democracies that are afraid in the very
basics of governance from brexit to the
yellow vests democracy is hard work just
ask any of the folks seeing here Stephen
Levitsky and Daniel's it Blatz say in
their treaties how democracies die quote
today the guardrails of American
democracy are weakening by the time
Barack Obama became president many
Republicans questioned the legitimacy of
their Democratic rivals and that
abandoned forbearance for a strategy of
winning by any means necessary Donald
Trump may have accelerated this process
but he didn't cause it the challenges
facing American democracy run deeper the
weakening of our democratic norms is
rooted in extreme partisan polarization
and that extends beyond policy
differences into an existential conflict
over race and culture and if one thing
is clear from studying breakdowns
throughout history it's that extreme
polarization can
kill democracies my friends democracy is
much more than holding an election
somewhere and it's become much clearer
to all of us here on the stage than ever
before that we have to be far more
conscious about how our leadership looks
through other people's eyes and what
decisions we make to live up to our own
values and to meet our own interests
that has been true long before Donald
Trump came along when I was Secretary of
State I remember we endured a
self-inflicted government shutdown I
could feel the way it weakened a key
component of our national power
it wasn't irreparable or irreversible no
and the strength of our principles and
the strength of our people are still I
believe the envy of the world but being
a responsible democracy requires that we
don't walk ourselves to the brink of
every opportunity we get that we don't
ransom our credibility so you never want
anyone to ask whether we can be counted
on in international affairs you never
want anyone to ask but the Democratic
dysfunction could make them doubt the
power of America's example or our
staying power and you never want anyone
to ask whether a fast-paced world is
better suited to the efficiency of
autocratic decision-making rather than
lumbering deliberation of democracies I
remember pressing this case with another
foreign minister and I'll never forget
him leaning into me and saying with his
eyebrow raised how's your democracy
going it matters and I think every one
of the distinguished former secretaries
of defense who are here will tell you
that it affected their jobs because
militaries and governments around the
world always wanted to know that they
could count on the United States will
America be a credible partner so rather
than talk about whether democracy is
dying the liberal order is to fraying is
fraying this conference is about answers
analysis and action to ensure that the
outcomes become real and that they are
what we want them to be what we all hope
will be for the future of our nation I
ask you all to remember what happened to
the Constitutional Convention in
Philadelphia when the founding fathers
finished their hard work on a late
summer night and Ben Franklin walked out
of the hall there was a crowd gathered
to find out what they had done and a
woman shouted tell us dr. Franklin what
do we have a monarchy or a republic and
dr. Franklin said back to her a republic
if you can keep it that's the challenge
and our three distinguished panelists
here are going to share with us their
perceptions based on years of engagement
in public life and critical years
serving as Secretary of Defense for the
United States bill Cohen is a is a there
are two Republicans here bill Cohen is
deserves a special chair I think but
bill is a remarkable person I he was
there in the Senate when I got there and
he's a poet
he's written 14 books seven novels to
portray books he was to write poetry in
the United States Senate not I mean not
when he was and was really a superb
Secretary of Defense and there's a great
thinker in demand today around the world
for his opinions and views and where our
country is going and where the world is
going Chuck Hagel the great friend of
mine
we both served in Vietnam Chuck was
served with great distinction he served
with his brother they're both wounded
and a very important voice the United
States Senate from Nebraska who
ultimately the private sector a
businessman prior to coming to the
Senate and
then became secretary defense serving in
the second term at president obama and
and of course Leon Panetta is mr. go-to
for everything I was and he he began his
life and politics as a Republican during
the Nixon administration he quickly left
over his differences over civil rights
and how they want to be spoken about and
enforced and then he went to a series of
jobs from the OMB where he headed up the
OMB to being chief of staff in the White
House to being CIA director and and
Secretary of Defense so we got a lot of
experience here a lot of people who
share opinions and without any further
ado I'm going to be sort of the try to
guide it but you're gonna hear from them
for the rest of the time here so join me
in welcoming our very very distinguished
[Applause]
so let me ask each of you if you'd sort
of respond to that encapsulation of some
where we find ourselves today I'd like
to say that everyone here has run for
office because Leon served in the House
of Representatives for many years I
think you just have a budget committee
for our call at one point so which is
what led him to OMB so they all
understand what it means to run for
office they also understand what it
means to make a deal
try to get things done so Leon perhaps
you'd weigh in first since you're you've
really felt this in many different ways
from the executive as well as on the
elected side well first of all thank you
John for inviting us and it's great to
be with my my colleagues bill and Chuck
who I've served with not only when I was
Secretary of Defense had their guidance
but work with them when they were in the
Congress as well and my thanks to the
Jackson Institute for pulling these
kinds of forums together secretaries of
defense we all know that this country
has the strongest military on the face
of the earth I always felt confident as
Secretary of Defense and not only the
quality of the resources that I had the
weaponry that I had but most importantly
because of the men and women in uniform
that served this country none better any
place in the world so I was always
confident of the ability to achieve the
mission but as defense secretary you
need to have leadership in the country
that tells you when and why
and whether you should fight otherwise
if you don't have that leadership it's
like having an arm ship without a
captain we we have tried that in in
history I mean I think one of the
dangers I see today is that we don't
remember the lessons of history that
well we've been through this where there
were those who decided to stand aside
let the world try to take care of its
own problems and not get involved I
think was President Reagan at the 40th
anniversary of Normandy who said we have
learned the bitter lessons of two world
wars and the one lesson we have clearly
learned is that isolationism never was
and never will be an acceptable response
by the United States and and I believe
that I think it's important that we
recognize that we have to provide that
leadership why because of our values
because of who we are because of of what
we represent to the world in terms of
our freedoms because we are a country
that is built alliances built based on
the same values this is a dangerous
world we'll talk about it but it's a
dangerous world there's a lot of
flashpoints in the world that could
become a major controversy or a major
conflict of some kind democracy is in
trouble as John pointed out we've got
nationalism and populism and
authoritarian governments beginning to
really surge and at the same time we are
a country that has very frankly
leadership and institutions that are not
adapting to the challenges I think
Washington is dysfunctional today in
both the President and both houses of
Congress and that hurts our democracy so
in the end
I believe that the key here is to
remember the lessons of history I think
the key is to remember what our values
are all about but in the end the most
important key is to find the right
leadership I tell the students at the
Panetta Institute in a democracy we
govern either by leadership or by crisis
if leadership is there we can avoid
crisis but otherwise will govern by
crisis the choice today is not between
patriotism and globalism the choice
today is between leadership or crisis
Thank You Leon bill would you sub add
into that but also as you do perhaps
answer the question of the bold
assertion that Leon made which I agree
with that Washington is completely
dysfunctional and maybe get into how
that could impact security or might have
impacted your job as you were doing it
okay well let me join with Leon and
thank you for hosting us and thank the
Jackson it stood for supporting it I'd
like to talk just a little bit about the
leadership in the sense of moral
leadership it's one thing to have the
big is the best the finest military in
the world but that really isn't where
our strength is our strength is in our
moral leadership throughout the world
and I think that is what is meant
desperately missing now we have an a
moral leadership dystonia in the White
House and immoral on given instances but
a moral to be sure and that's something
I think we need to raise up the the
Latin very high to say this is what the
United States stands for this is what
democracy means this is who we are and
I'll give you one a good example of that
and Bob Woodward who's sitting here who
knows more about how Washington works or
doesn't work than anyone will know that
I've told him this I was sitting in
Seoul Korea is in 2008
and the head of a group of former
national leaders and I think they
thought I was Joe Biden why they invited
me I was sitting next to a member of the
South Korean cabinet and he turned to me
he said you know he said if Barack Obama
gets elected next week he said it'll be
easy in these exact words the
reaffirmation of the American Dream and
I thought that what away a nice way to
have phrased that the reaffirmation of
the American Dream and I said what do
you say that he said because if you can
take a first-generation African American
who becomes president the United States
it means that anything is possible and I
said that's what the United States means
here in this country anything is
possible and that's why we are held out
as leaders that's what we represent to
the world in terms of leadership the
morality behind it the fact that we
believe in democracy the fact that we
believe in inclusion the fact that we
believe that everybody should be given
an opportunity to be the best that they
can be that's what we represent to the
world yes we have a military to back it
up and yes we have diplomats to carry
out our foreign policies but if you
don't have a moral principle behind it
other contribution say you know we we
like Putin better we like President Xi
better we like Kim Jong on and so I
think unless we get back to the moral
fiber of what makes this country truly
great then we're going to see the
dissolution of this country in terms of
all that it represents to the rest of
the world we're seeing that take place
now and secretary Kerry's asked me how
do I feel going around the world it
depends on where you go if you go to
those countries which support
autocracies and authoritarian leaders
they like they like what's happening if
you go to those countries who
have depended upon us for their support
economic and military and moral they're
disappointed they want to know how could
this take place in America and so we're
losing them we're losing them to other
countries because where is a moral gap
and we're retrenching and we're turning
inward and we're turning against each
other and we're calling each other names
and engaging in identity politics
identity destruction and so it's a real
crisis of morality taking place and so
the American people have to decide who
are we what role do we play in this
world of turmoil and information
overload and unless we decide who we are
then I think the forces the entrepot
forces are going to destroy us so we
have a great opportunity but I think you
have to get our moral leadership back
and I think I'll stop here because I
think secretary Hagel has much more to
say on this so I'm going to come back in
a minute bill because I particularly
want to follow up on the morality issue
with respect to culture which you
mentioned but also race but Chuck can
you I want you to tackle this sort of
overall if she would initially but also
speak to the issue of how you come back
from that what what are the things that
are missing now that we need to get back
to that will make the greatest
difference the fastest John thank you to
the jackson Institute I echo what penny
on and Bill have said in thanks to all
who are involved were involved continued
to be involved in holding these kind of
symposiums and meetings and gatherings
to focus on what's really truly
important for the future of this country
since 1945 at the end of World War two
the one indispensable requisites
has been American leadership we led in
building a world order in that 10-year
period after World War two that has
served the world pretty well
imperfect hasn't solved all the problems
but you think of what has been
accomplished with American leadership
and our allies and I want to focus on
allies for a moment because alliances
are absolutely critical we could not
have been as productive as secure as
good as we are without our friends our
allies and the alliances that we built
but what I have often referred to as
coalition's of common interests United
Nations NATO IMF World Bank WTO those
institutions were built because of the
common interests that most nations had
not that we all agreed on everything and
not that we were always going to agree
on new things but we had enough common
interest to build a platform where we
could work from those common interests
to fix where we disagree no World War
three pretty significant especially
every World War two generation leader
went to their graves concerned about a
world war three no nuclear exchange
pretty significant more advances in
every discipline in the history of
mankind medicine agriculture any
discipline technology in the years since
World War two we've accomplished a lot a
lot more to do a lot more to do but we
built a system where we could self
correct just like America's system
America's system allows us to
self-correct when we wrote the
Constitution to preamble we didn't get
it all right
a hundred years ago half the people in
this room could not vote unless you were
a white male landowner when we started
this great experiment you didn't have
all the rights if the Constitution said
you did we have 27 amendments to the
Constitution because we
correct we fix things and we brought
that I think as much as any other thing
to the world the last 70 years now where
are we today how do we work our way back
well bill and and Leon both mentioned
it's up to us I mean it starts here in
our country with our people the values
the standards we're imperfect people we
make mistakes make mistakes every day
we haven't gotten all our foreign policy
right over the years made some big
mistakes but we keep getting better we
keep trying and we are foundational
anchored by the principles and the
morals and the standards and the beliefs
that we can be better and and unless we
call us around that and build that back
and we have leaders that believe that
and believe in institutions that every
institution in this country is bigger
and better than any leader I mean we're
just passing stewards on the scene
hopefully we make it better but we have
to rely on institutions and that's
really what's happened politically I
think in this country as much as
anything else when John talked about
Trump for example not being the cause he
wasn't because he was the consequence of
the tone in this country the lack of
confidence respect and Trust in our
institutions certainly in Washington he
said the news media Gallup does a poll
every year that measures trust and
confidence in the 15 leading
institutions in the country education
religion only the military comes out
well they're right in the 70% out range
only one other institution this year
came out over 50 percent of confidence
of trusting American people that was
small business well we all know I mean
mom and pop I mean who's against them
they're good people the little guy I
mean he's not out to hurt anybody but
big business education journalism
obviously politics Washington DC down in
the teens and single digits so I
think that's where we start to build
back confidence and trust in who we are
and start to use our institutions what
we want to be that we can be better and
that reflects around the world
we can't lead the world ever not just
with a strong military or not just with
a strong economy it takes more than that
and these three gentlemen know that
they've lived it in their lives the
leadership is about character it's about
integrity it's about trust
that's what leadership is about and
every nation in the world serves in its
own self-interest we do individuals do
there's nothing wrong with that but it's
blending those self-interest into common
interests that makes the world work and
we have to go back to some of the real
standards that were set after World War
Two and that World War two generation
that understood that and and we all get
the world back with us populism
nationalism I understand that what's
going on in the world we've got that in
the United States because we've lost
trust in each other it won't be easy it
won't be quick but it can be done and
that's generally kind of my thinking
that we can get more into specifics in
this Congress so I want to try to do
that Chuck as we go forward here for
sure can I do this if I could do one
thing absolutely but so no could you do
a favor I think I left the Levitsky zip
black book in the car and there is a
quote in there I'd love to share with
everybody thank you I just want to jump
in on what Chuck has been saying can I
ask you to as you do to perhaps share
with people how what is happening today
and how the current political dynamic
would affect you in your goals as
secretary defense and protecting the
country I want to pick up on what Chuck
has said about the respect for our
military being one of the few
institutions where the people have
extraordinary trust there is a danger
that if we don't care that support will
diminish and will diminish because what
is taking place by our president
who insists that the military is his
military and talked during the course of
the campaign I will order my generals to
waterboard any of the persons that we
have I will order them to torture and my
generals will carry this out and I
rebelled at that notion my generals are
his generals it's not his army they
represent the American people and today
what he is doing is basically
politicizing the military much as he's
tried to politicize the intelligence
community when you see that the
president meeting with President Putin
says that I don't believe the unanimous
decision and conclusion by our
intelligence community that the Russians
attempted to interfere with our
democratic process he said before I
believe Putin I don't believe Liang he
is when he says that he doesn't believe
the assessments of the intelligence
community and he says it publicly time
after time what does that do that tells
all of those in the intelligence
community don't bring me any bad news
you bring me news that I want to hear
that is in danger of then politicizing
the product that comes to the president
who has to make decisions so we're in
danger of having a person in the White
House who's using instruments of power
in a way to politicize them in my
judgment and ways that have not been
done before that are going unaccounted
for Nixon tried to do it surely during
the Watergate period but he was held
accountable for it the president at this
point can say that I want you to go out
members of ice I want you to go out and
I want you to deport or bring that
person and get him out of the country
and if you break the law I will pardon
you I've never heard of a president
United States telling somebody to go
break the law and I'll give you a pardon
he said it during the course of the
campaign says go punch that person out
if they sue you I'll defend you I'll pay
for your attorney we're seeing elements
now in our own
society which are diminishing the
integrity of all of our institutions so
I can go after Congress I can go after
the media it's corrupt I can go after
the intelligence community I can go
after whenever it is and diminish it and
so it's now fake news not real news and
so there's a reason why we're losing
confidence in our institutions some of
it's our own fault for failing to
perform what our obligations are but
when the leadership comes from the top
and when the leader of this country Dara
gates and diminish and degrades our
institutions as well as our people as
well as people of color in this country
then we're on the road to what John
Kerry was talking about earlier we're on
the road to journey we're on the road to
fascism if you can do that and get away
with it and have your party support you
unquestionably can you speak to that for
a minute bill I applaud the thought of
stopping a no-no but I want to it's
important to focus in on this because it
goes to what has to be done one of the
important ingredients of the
diminishment of democracy is the beating
down of your opponents the isolation of
your opponents the the and a coupled by
a very significant retrenchment from
accountability you have no
accountability so here we have people
who privately will get you've heard it
you know what some of your former
colleagues are saying in Washington
about the president as mental capacity
is ability to lead is ability to energy
but they go up there and they vote with
it so in the end is this a
responsibility it falls on other people
here and the people who aren't here to
exercise what I talked about earlier
which is that vote or to become more
conscious of it and how do you do that
when you are self selecting in your news
media that everybody goes to and the
result is you have reinforcement not new
information as a result you know that
mean the reality is that our system of
checks and balances is being tested as
probably never before in my lifetime
because our forefathers did not want to
put all the power in a king
they didn't want power in the Congress
and they didn't want power in a Star
Chamber Court so that's why they created
the system of checks and balances that's
there and the ultimate check-in balance
is really we the people look you know
the reality is and I think it's true for
all of us up here on the stage we've
seen Washington at its best and we're
seeing Washington at its worst and the
good news is we've seen Washington work
yeah when I first went back to
Washington as a legislative assistant
you know there were Republicans but ever
dirksen worked for a Republican from
California a lot of moderate Republicans
and they work with Democrats you know
people like Humphrey and Kennedy and at
fulbright dick Russell they work
together on issues because they felt
that was important when I got elected to
the Congress Tip O'Neill was the speaker
a democrats democrat from boston but he
had a great friendship with Bob Michael
who was the Minority Leader and yes did
they have their political differences of
course that they fight each other in
elections yes but when he came to big
issues they work together and ultimately
it really comes down I mean when I was
in the Congress to exercise the kind of
leadership you have to exercise requires
risk it requires sacrifice I mean you
have to if you're going to make tough
decisions about issues that face this
country you've got to be willing to take
risk otherwise you're not much of a
leader and the reality is that you know
I remember when we did the budget in the
Clinton administration tough votes 500
billion in deficit reduction 250 billion
in tax increases 250 billion in spending
cuts across the board
that's a tough vote and we passed it by
one vote in the house and in the Senate
but in the end the result of that
combined with the agreement that the
Bush administration made we balanced the
budget we had a surplus is it tough
are there some members that lost their
seats you're damn right but it isn't all
about politics today yeah when we
weren't their governing was good
politics it really was
if you govern even though you made tough
decisions it's good politics today I'm
not sure they think that governing is
good politics and that's what we
resulting in this dysfunction because
both parties are in their trenches I've
never seen it as partisan as it is today
and and the president basically feeds in
to that mean sense of partisanship so
ultimately we got to get back now
there's one ray of hope that I'll share
with you and I my youngest son got
elected to my old seat in the Congress a
couple terms ago Jimmy Jimmy was Jimmy's
a veteran we served in Afghanistan and
got the Bronze Star but there are a lot
of veterans and there are a lot of
younger members who don't want to just
go back there and pound their shoe on
the table and so they've created a
solutions caucus they just established a
veteran's caucus Republicans and
Democrats look this thing isn't going to
change from the top down it's not going
to change with this leadership either in
the Congress or in the White House it's
going to have to change from the bottom
up so ultimately it's we the people that
are going to have to produce the kind of
change necessary if we want to see
leadership so let me share a quick thing
and I don't want to infer the
conversation but in 1994 I remember in
the Senate distinctly perceptibly seeing
a difference in how the Senate conducted
itself what happened is with the
Gingrich revolution 1994 what happened
as people started to come over from the
house bringing a different sort of
attitude about bomb-throwing and
and and and intellectual / ideological
orthodoxy that was required of people
and now in the last year's we're seeing
senators threatened within the caucus
with the possibility of a primary they
don't fear a general election partly
because of the gerrymandering in America
they fear the general election
excuse me they fear the primary they
fear the potential and people have
actually thought you don't vote with us
in this we're going to primary you and
there's a level of antipathy but but let
me just say quickly that you've had a
breaking of the norms there are a set of
norms that existed in American politics
and as the authors of how democracies
die point out if those norms change you
lose the basis it's not the Constitution
itself that that that regiments
everything that happens politically it's
the behavior of people who are trying to
interpret it and enforce it live by it
and so here's what in June of his 1978
campaign this is what Newt Gingrich he
met with a group of college Republicans
at the Atlanta Airport and and he he he
said the following he warned them just
quote to stop using boy scout words
which would be great around the campfire
but a lousy in politics he continued
you're fighting a war it is a war for
power this party does not need another
generation of cautious prudent careful
bland irrelevant quasi leaders what we
really need are people who are willing
to stand up in a slugfest what's the
primary purpose of a political leader it
to build a majority and what did Mitch
McConnell say when what's the priority
when Barack Obama was to make him a
one-term president what was the it's to
build the majority to hold on to it not
to affect the great things for the
country so Lilliana is 100% correct
about this issue of accountability being
in the voters but there are other
crosscurrents that people need to I
think grapple with in this you talked
about the moral issue
I remember President
we're waiting to do something at the UN
we're in a room waiting and we were
talking about where we were and that's
dysfunctional political process and he
shared with me his conviction that an
awful lot of it was race was race-based
and he felt it more than anybody because
he saw the mail that came in to the
White House he knew what the threats
were that to see that the Secret Service
was dealing with a cetera and and that
is if you look at what's happening now
with the language being use with the
immigration issue being exploited
everything is negative no aspiration no
going to the moon no we're gonna do this
because it's hard but but a sort of
appeal to the lowest common denominator
denominator of American politics not the
highest so what I mean is it your sense
that the electorate is actually willing
to listen and able to listen right now
to a different appeal well and this is
one of the last moderate Republicans in
the Senate thank you
[Laughter]
I consider that a great compliment not
all my Republican friends do but I
always have on that point yes I'm a
Republican but I always tried to be a
United States Senator who was an
American first and I never got confused
about that doesn't mean I'm any better
than anybody else but my guiding
principle and then I get to your
question John was we all take an oath of
office it's same for all of us and the
oath of office is not to a party or to a
president it's to your country there's
the Constitution so that should be the
North Star for everybody that you're
talking about the issues and all that we
have referenced here I know that's tough
it cost some people their seats but you
shouldn't be in this business if if you
just you want to keep getting reelected
for no purpose as John's talking about
majority billed majority keep majority
but for what purpose do you want to
really help America do you want to
help us get better improve the
inequities in this country that that's
the point but John you know you talk
about leadership and we've all been
talking about what the problems are how
do we get better and how do you how do
you fix this and your specific question
to me I think the timing of this has to
occur not because leaders tell the
people you got to do it now I think
that's important but the timing will
come when majority of the people of this
country decide that you know we've had
enough of this we are so much better
than what we're seeing what our
government is doing you wouldn't raise
your children with the same kind of
standards in values and aspirations that
American people see in their leaders
today no parent would ever tolerate that
and so it has to come from the people
because that's who we are I mean we're
not kings we're not presidents for life
I mean defense secretaries for life what
ask you what effect does this chaotic
public political body of the country
have on the troops and on the ability to
coalesce them around a particular ideal
which is worth dying for
well that's the particularly good
question I think for us but but for the
audience to and you because you saw it
and you served and so you know it from a
lot of sides it confuses I think troops
i bill and I flew in from Washington
this morning and there was an honor
flight I think most of you are familiar
with honor flights and it recognized
veterans knew or you and I are standing
there as a people who plotted and went
to buy drinks or coffee or hotdogs or
whatever we let the veterans go on not
the veterans active duty going first and
on all flights and all those kinds of
things but but I think we confuse them
military when they see all that they
hear the words but yet less than one
percent of the American people wear the
uniform
well that's somebody else in all clap
form and do that but then when when the
troops see the complete distance and the
American public really they wonder when
we send them in to Iraq and we send them
in to Syria and the places that we all
have sent troops into they're confused
by that and is it the policy is the
policy right are we doing the right
thing for the world for us is is this
morally right I mean we yes we always
must make decisions in our best
interests of course we do that's
realistic but there's more to it than
that I think it's one of confusion John
for our troops what's happening you add
to that we have an Assistant Secretary
of Defense along with a number of other
acting what I'm sorry
acting Secretary of Defense along with
other Acting secretaries and positions
that are not filled what happens is make
no mistake about it at the Defense
Department if you have an Acting
Secretary of Defense everybody is trying
to I this guy to try to figure out
whether he's ever going to really be
appointed Secretary of Defense or
whether they're dealing with some kind
of secondhand goods in terms of that
individual and so yeah even within the
Defense Department questions are going
to be raised about having an acting
secretary and then you combine that with
these kind of mixed messages that the
president sends you know look the reason
we support alliances is because it has
been critical to our national security
as CIA director I depended on our allies
to provide in key information to us
about threats that were out there we
were willing to share information
important to our national security when
I was Secretary of Defense just like
these guys we fought alongside our
allies
I mean after 9/11 NATO came to war with
us in Iraq in Afghanistan against
al-qaeda we we have fought alongside of
them and they put their lives on the
line as well and if you have a president
that questions the credibility of these
alliances or whether there are even
necessary and questions whether or not
you know intelligence from your own
people is verifiable or real what what
bill talked about you can't imagine the
impact that had on the morale of our
intelligence people when he says I trust
the Russian better than I trust my own
intelligence people magic you're putting
your life on this on the line we have
sources out there that are in sensitive
positions and you have the president
United States basically saying I don't
give a damn what our intelligence people
are saying so we ask an awful lot of our
men and women in uniform we ask an awful
lot of our people and intelligence to do
the right job but for them they need to
have the support of their leadership for
what they're doing and if they question
that I mean what is happening well and I
hate to acknowledge it but I think it's
a fact is that we are weakening America
by virtue of that kind of leadership can
I just follow up on Leon has just said
in terms of the impact upon our military
the military has been in the forefront
of social change advancing social change
in this country from integration to gays
in the military to transgenders in the
middle of serving in the military and
the confusion is coming about now
because we have to come back and in this
whole issue and identify who we who are
we
now you're part of the elite we're part
of the elite so we're not talking for
many of the people who are supporting
the president but the president when he
says what he diminishes other people
based on race or sexual identity or
other preferences he basically is
dividing this country in a way that's
confusing to the men and women who were
serving us because they've come to
understand what it means to work
together to see each other as part of
the whole team and what is most
discouraging to me is that you know
we're still fighting the civil war in
this country it has not ended and what
he is doing basically is appealing to
those white middle-aged less
college-educated people who have lost
their jobs and we haven't talked about
globalization and immigration what the
impact has been on that but he's talking
to them and he's talked to them based on
race if you look at the spread of
populism right-wing populism around the
world it's mostly white countries
whether it's in Poland or Russia or
Hungary or the Czech Republic in Germany
now we have a hundred members of the
alt-right in Germany now in part of
Parliament they're now saying the
neo-nazi slogans coming up more and more
and you see that what's taking place in
this country at the most black people
the thugs they're criminals they're
branded it's one professor as nd Efendi
was said black people are branded from
the beginning and what the president is
doing is he's keeping he's focusing on
that to divide us against each other and
that is part of the technique that John
Kerry was talking about this book keep
people divided if you had to take the
playbook of President Putin what would
be his bucket list number one brexit
let's divide up the the British Empire
over here what used to be number two EU
let's break up the the
number three let's attack the media as
being false number four let's attack
elected officials in democracies as
being against you they're not with you
they're part of the elite and then
number five go after the intelligence
community and keep dividing keep
dividing people from each other so we've
got to decide is is this a country that
is going to try and heal if we must or
we're going to keep rewarding people who
are really feeding upon this racial
divide that we still have in this
country so we've got to come to grips
with this issue of race you're gonna
have Tracy Abrams I think talk to you
and others far better than me to be
discussing this subject but I see what's
happening and the last thing I want to
see is our military be politicized and
have the military confused is it okay to
be gay in the military is it okay to be
a transgender in the military are we
really of fighting as one or we being
divided along racial lines that we
thought we had left behind so these are
issues that we haven't even begun to
touch upon it's that's a short segment
I'll confine my normally long remarks
globalization immigration those issues
are big issues in terms of what's
contributed to the disenchantment in
this country I think it's worth bill I
think we should take a few minutes here
we do have time and I want to get you
guys to focus on the people
participating in this on so the
consequences of everything you've just
talked about I mean I think most people
sort of see this happening but not
enough people are understanding okay
what's the opportunity cost in all of
this for instance cyber is as dangerous
today as nuclear weapons were in the
1950s we created a structure we're not
haven't done anything about cyber there
are no rules of the road and everybody's
attacking everybody every single day
that's a danger America ought to be
thinking about the INF treaty the START
treaty that they're beginning now to
pull apart we could have another nuclear
arms race
in this we could spend a trillion
dollars whatever Trump wants to he's
trying to so that debate is not taking
place so what are the consequences of in
your judgment of the real security needs
of our nation to be responding
proactively to these kinds of challenges
and what are they I think you know look
the bottom line is I think our security
is at risk and you know I'll just tell
you you you watch watch this the
campaign that's going on now with all of
the candidates that are out there there
really is not a lot of talk about the
threats that were confronting in the
world or what we need to do about it I
realize you know everybody's kind of
focused on health care and and the
economy and jobs and issues related to
prescription drugs and things like that
but they're also focusing on the
political attacks that are going on
every day and the tweets that the
president does and and that is the back
and forth that the press is consumed by
but the reality is if you're if you're
running for president United States
where the hell do you stand on the
challenges and flashpoints that we're
facing the world where do you stand on
Russia and how we deal with Russia which
has become more aggressive and more
threatening where do you stand on China
and how we deal with China and their
militarization of the South China Sea
and the threats that they can constitute
where do you stand on Iran and how we
deal with Iran where do you stand on
North Korea and dealing with that threat
of nuclear is a ssin that they're
involved with and now we're ever going
to do nuke denuclearize North Korea
where do you stand on failed States in
the Middle East Syria Yemen Libya all
becoming breeding grounds for terrorism
where do you stand on Isis and al Qaeda
and Boko Haram and Al Shabaab where do
you stand on cyber which is the
battlefield of the future
none of that even the president doesn't
talk a lot about these things and yet
those are the those are the
responsibilities of the next president
of the United States there ought to be a
focus on where the hell do they stand on
national security issues that involve
whether or not our country is going to
be strong in the future and it's also
fair from the beginning of your answer I
think you're saying yes obviously
there's a security impact on the United
States and the negative because of this
process can I go ahead I wanted to
follow on with what Leon said answering
your question opportunity costs the way
where you put the question to America I
mean what are the costs for us with with
this kind of tepid dysfunctional
polarized leadership no leadership
we don't govern well let's just go
around the horn here one belt one road
China mm-hmm most of you are familiar
with that the inroads that China is
making one belt one road the link all
the old trade routes from China around
the world they just did a big deal with
Italy the Italian President signed a
deal a NATO country EU country there's a
huge one right there what the President
did taking us out of TPP which you and I
both helped negotiate you were there too
I was handling the Italian side but you
did well
I mean opportunity costs there for us
which the Chinese and the Russians are
moving in the Arctic when you and I John
testified last week on climate change
that was a serious proposition that's
serious the Arctic what what what's
happening up there the Russians for
example are reinstituting their old
bases a national security bases that
they gave up after the implosion the
Soviet
they have 48 new ice cutters we have two
old ice cutters Russians have 48
state-of-the-art the Chinese have about
a dozen new ice cutters China is playing
up there so you look at what China is
doing obviously in their sphere of
Commerce in Asia edging us out what the
Russians are doing edging us out in some
of the European countries because of
what Bill talked about populism
nationalism these are huge cost us that
we we can't get back once they are so
far committed air21 we've got this
problem with air21 buying surface-to-air
missiles from russia
well that was there when you were there
and I was there you were there but we so
mishandled that it didn't have to come
to this I think NATO is is on the verge
of losing turkey I mean in essence they
have not been an active member turkey
for four years these are huge costs to
the next generation of Americans and
then you talk about cyber and technology
what China is doing there
absolutely we don't see it really yet
but the next generation of Americans
will and the other thing about that is
that that really erodes our alliances
and our allies well why would we side
with America why would we adjust to what
America wants like we used to do because
you're not driving the train anymore
it's a new day America it's a new day
and that's what I think the American
public is missing unfortunately I think
that's what our leaders are missing I
know whether they're missing it or they
just don't want to do anything about it
but this is this is damn serious let me
underscore if I may the the consequence
of what is happening in Europe is really
potentially disastrous in the following
way I know how many of you saw but it's
worth taking note of and really looking
under underneath it the letter that
former Pope Benedict wrote which was
diametrically opposed to the position of
Pope Francis even though he's live
in the Vatican etc that's Panetta's area
Steve Steve Bannon has opened an office
in Italy's very close to Salvi knees
working sell beanies opened in office in
Spain he has an office in Brussels and
there is a genuine concern but no one's
paying attention to that well no one
here is paying attention our leadership
is so lacking if we were paying
attention to it we would be able to do
something about it we had genuine
diplomacy and leadership here but the
result is that you will have a European
election that could wind up with the
grassroots populism capitalizing on the
chaos of brexit the chaos of what's
happening in France the GA zone chaos of
the alt-right and Germany in the sense
of transition from Angela Merkel so
there's a weakness there which could
potentially be hugely exploited by the
parliamentary elections for the European
Parliament if you had a European
Parliament that came in that hates
Brussels and hates the purpose of being
elected we're in a whole new ballgame
folks with respect to the European
project so the costs of this is what I'm
talking about the opportunity cost is
really gigantic now let me ask all three
of you President Xi is busy running
around the world he gave the speech at
the at the World Economic Forum he has
given it in a number of other countries
the speech is that the liberal order of
the West is dead this is the Chinese
century and the United States of America
is in decline President Putin is also
going around spreading that narrative
and is cutting deals in Africa and
elsewhere and we're pretty absent we're
absent financially or absent
diplomatically so what is are they right
are they saying America is in decline
and the liberal order of the West is in
fact if not dead moribund and and in
transition where are we yeah the answer
is yes they're saying that they believe
it and they have reason to believe it
because they look at us and we talked at
the opening of this session that we're
dysfunctional
so they can look at us and say you guys
can't make a decision I can make a
decision in China I can decide I'm going
to build this built-in road I can decide
I'm going to have a highest rail a
Speedway that can take you from all the
way from Beijing to Shanghai in five
five and a half hours six hours I can do
all of these things because I have the
power by the way I have the power for
life so there are a number of countries
looking to China looking to Russia
looking to Turkey is saying these
countries function we don't like what
they're doing but they are acting and
they're getting some things done the
only thing we have to lose is our
freedom and our individuality willing to
give that up and if you go and we're
helping them we are helping them for
example you mentioned TPP when person
Trump was elected I had voted early
openly for Hillary Clinton and I went
and I arrived in Beijing and I had a
private dinner with a very high-level
Chinese official he was sitting side by
side he said tell me one thing
now that Trump has been elected that
mean TPP is dead and I said
unfortunately yes he said good good we
gave them TPP and they were worried
about it for a good reason
a year later all of the ASEAN countries
come to the United States at the Center
for the Strategic and International
Studies CSIS and there on the podium
like this and to a person they express
their frustration with the United States
and one of them said we trusted you for
seven years and we wasted seven years
negotiating this deal not only we waste
seven years with you but you've just
credited us with our own constituents so
their attitude is not one how can we be
close to you with their look fending
from themselves and by the way they
happen to be the orbit of China so we're
doing this to ourselves because we don't
have a strategy we have a president who
thinks tactically who thinks
transactionally who sees one subject
he'll focus on an issue
make it worse and then say come back and
say I solved the problem I did it and
he's done that with the Canadian with
the Canadians with the Mexicans he's
doing it now with China and I just came
back from China I have offices over in
China I just came back from there
they're looking forward to a deal being
struck with the United States so is our
business community looking forward to it
but it won't be a deal that really gets
at the heart of what the Chinese are
able to do and that won't get at the
heart of it because they'll agree to buy
hundreds of billions of more soybeans or
whatever it is we want to sell them it
won't change the structure whereby they
are pouring money into there what they
call the SOE state-owned enterprises
picking out the ten top sectors of the
economy for the future whether it's
cyber artificial intelligence medicine
it's they pick these ten out and they're
going to be number one and they're going
to pour the money into that and we are
sitting back and saying no we're gonna
have this deal we just but I'm more
stuff from us we'll be okay so we're
doing it to ourselves and we have to
wake up or be woke it happens as the
saying goes we got to be woke about
what's going on that we don't have a
strategy all we're doing is tactically
taking on one issue and doing it poorly
in my judgment but let less you get the
impression that everything's going to
hell
[Laughter]
and look I think all of us reflect our
own experience and the fact that all of
us thought when you know our democracy
was was working and had to deal with the
challenges it faces and I know that
there are articles now about the old
world order coming to an end
and the power shifts that are going on
but I think we all we should also think
about our strengths in this country we
do have a strong economy we do have the
strongest military on the face of the
earth with as I said the best fighting
force men and women ever
in terms of their capability and we also
have I think in the American people and
and I've had a chance to you know go
around the entire country like like my
friends here you know the real strength
of this country really does rests with
the spirit and resilience of the
American people and the fact is if you
go into communities if you go into
cities if you go into many of the states
you know it's working you know that and
it isn't about Democrat or Republican I
mean there are communities here that are
dealing with a lot of challenges because
they're working together and because
they care for one another and so there
is I think a resilience in this country
and we saw it in the last election I
mean the fact is people went to the
polls and created an even bit more
effective check in Washington by
electing a Democratic House so you know
I I realized that you know there are a
lot of concerns but I think ultimately
we also have to look at the history of
this country we've had 200 years of
history we have faced crises in the past
on civil wars world wars recessions
depressions and somehow we've always
been able ultimately to rise to the
occasion with the right leadership and I
I think I think it will happen again but
it'll take your involvement I mean if
you sit there and just say everything's
going to hell and so what you know I'll
deal with my family I'll deal with my
community that's fine but you've got to
be involved you've got to play a role
and make a difference in our democracy
this this system does not work if you
are not involved and making a difference
and ultimately it really is going to be
up to you so we're coming towards what
was the scheduled closing of this but
we're going to go on a little bit longer
for two reasons one we've got a little
bit of
number two we want to get you involved
in it and I think there's an opportunity
where there was an opportunity to submit
some questions where cards handed out am
I correct hello somebody okay if there
are no cards we're not going to be
selective we're gonna we're going to
just open it up here for a minute yes
sir over there thank you so much to the
speakers
I was wondering Phyllis it was a name
and tell us what school you're in
absolutely things my name is George
gemelas I'm from Indiana and I'm in the
forestry school in the fifth year
program from a military perspective what
are the ways in which climate
instability are a threat to democracy
here and abroad if I could when I was
CIA director I thought it was important
to establish a section that CIA that
would focus on intelligence on climate
change and what was taking place and I
did the same thing when I was Secretary
of Defense I thought it was important to
have a climate change section at defense
to a focus on the threats what are the
dangers we're already seeing that the
melting of the Arctic and the
establishment of a passage and what the
Russians are doing to take advantage of
that that's happening rising seas and
the impact that will have not only are
in our basis but on populations that
live near the ocean and what that can do
to create threats droughts that result
weather changes that are that create
consequences as well you can look at a
number of areas in which because of
climate change and because of its impact
are creating population movements that
in themselves could produce future
threats to our security so there are a
number of areas we should be on top of
it
unfortunately the administration's view
on climate change
has closed down what the CIA was doing
and what the Department of Defense was
doing and I think they're blindsiding on
a very important area of threats as a
result I was just I would just add to it
Leon said and everything he said it
exactly right I mentioned that secretary
Kerry and I testified last week for the
House Oversight Committee on climate
change national security effects trade
diplomacy and so on
and if I had to summarize an answer to
you effects on our military and all our
the other interests we have is
instability climate change brings
instability instability is dangerous in
a dangerous combustible world because
that means pandemic health issues when I
was secretary we had the Ebola breakout
in western Africa and it was the
Department of Defense that changed all
of that because we had the capacity we
had the planes with the Corps of
Engineers could build hospitals and
clinics we had the doctors we had the
nurses we had the money we had it all
and it was it was the Defense Department
that came to the rescue
it's a good example of what Defense
Department does in addition to fighting
wars all kinds of natural disasters it's
always DoD because we have the equipment
but that instability represents a huge
problem for all of us in the world and
you added at that instability to some of
the other factors here with Leon talked
about and others then you've got a
potential here for an awful awful big
problem in the future when I was right
after I took over from Leon and in
Halifax Canada in November of 2014 I
announced the first DoD Arctic strategy
for defense and building on his work and
other secretaries bills that came before
us and then an implementation plan and
DOD has really taken that and
all of that work over the years and
built something but and no one should
minimize no one should minimize the
threat of stability for our security and
I think bill one-meter blood story the
highlight of his testimony and secretary
Kerry is that one member of Congress has
said that he was introducing a bill that
very next day to say that not one penny
of the defense budget can be used to
study climate change the Defense
Department budget should be used for
more planes more guns well that's okay
Kerry said that's we don't mind a
statement like that because they didn't
ask us any questions he had all the
answers can I just say very quickly that
I see sue Binney I was sitting here sue
who's teaching her at Yale was our
brilliant legal counsel advisor as we
negotiated the Paris agreement and I
know she will agree with me this is this
is this is the biggest security issue we
face people just cannot avoid the
reality of what it means in food
production interruption instability
because of water scarcity high
temperatures people are living with
which they cannot live under and
therefore they will move if you see
people moving today Whittle then and
it's coming fires floods the combination
and they will be greater in intensity we
in Paris knew we weren't holding the
earth's temperature two degrees
centigrade which was what we were
targeting as a goal we knew that but we
were betting on the private sector being
able to invest and finding with the
technology and other things they need we
do to do unprecedented historic steps
which is not my language the language of
the IPCC and their 10 year 12 year
warning so if we don't heed that folks
we are literally living out a mutual
suicide pact here on earth and the
decisions that Donald Trump has made are
unequivocably costing lives and billions
of dollars of property and and probably
in the trillions going forward if we do
go up the way we're going to hit the two
but you know what we're on track to do
now if you want to be concerned we're on
track to go to four or four point five
degrees in this century so go read look
it up what the I'm not going to bore you
over the consequences whether it means
now but you know this is monumental and
what the president has done pull out
pull out of Paris pull out of the TPP
pull out of the Iran deal pulled out of
the INF talk about pulling out of start
but I mean it's it's it's just
staggering the level of consequence for
our children and grandchildren period
well just food production alone on this
I mean the consequences to food
production you could be mass starvation
in parts of the world because of climate
change well just like what so let's get
to another question up and back
somewhere am I want to be it's a
gentleman there where I all right sir
here we've done a Mike thank you so much
for being here
need Surrey from the School of
Management so well around the topic of
military spending in NATO and given the
number of socio-economic issues our
country deals with do you think we could
ever live in a reality where we don't
spend as much as we are on the military
but still be a well-functioning
democracy who is going to tackle that
well all started but I I'm sure my my to
learn did colleagues will finish it
since we're getting a blank check right
defense spending determines is
determined by the realities of the world
what the threats are what it takes to
keep you free and secure and I don't I
don't think you can look at it any other
way I mean I don't think you well we're
not going to spend any more than this
and that's it no matter what the threats
are no matter what the Chinese do the
Russian or anybody else that's it you
can't look at it that way I think when
you total up what we're talking about
right at seven
50 billion dollar budget now the Trump
administration has suggested plus and
another we were talking about this at
lunch a contingency fund for overseas
contingency operations which is very
dishonest it's off balance it's as bill
said it's a slush fund
I mean tens of billions of dollars I
think we've got adequate resources III
believe spending more our budget defense
budgets in the next ten defense budgets
in the world together so I think if we
manage it right we do make the right
decisions and so on but when you look at
the overall budget it is crowding out a
lot of other spending because it's of
what the Congress still has capacity to
determine in their spending it's more
than half of that that goes to defense
and the other part of that budget
because I think you have to factor in
the total budget here is the where is
all that money going in our federal
budget we've got the most expensive part
by far reaching close to half is for the
national debt entitlement programs
retirement programs in the military and
all those bunched up and that just keeps
growing and growing and growing and so
we're gonna have to make some pretty
tough choices we haven't talked about
the budget but that's because exactly
what I was going to comment on as a
former chairman of the Budget Committee
and OMB director both parties both
Republicans and Democrats have run away
from the responsibility to deal with
what is now a 22 trillion dollar
national debt and there are there are
those that now are saying oh well you
know don't don't worry about it we can
we can keep borrowing as long as we have
a strong economy but the reality is we
can't because those interest payments on
that debt are going to come back to rob
reefs
sources from whatever priority you want
and not only that would destabilize our
economy that's a reality but neither
party wants to confront this issue and
Chuck's right if you look at the federal
budget on discretionary funding that's
about 1/4 of the budget and defense
makes up a big chunk of that over half
two-thirds this goes to entitlement
programs and in addition to that there's
the issue of revenues taxes supporting
the federal government now what we did
when we we did those budget agreements
as we put everything on the table
everything we put a cap on discretionary
spending we put a cap on defense
spending you know it was a cap that
would grow with inflation but we put a
cap on defense spending and we also got
savings out of entitlement programs out
of Medicare out of Medicaid out of farm
support programs out of retirement
programs out of veterans programs you
can find savings in those program and by
the way you don't have to cut them
that's right
no you don't have to do it just better
better administration of those programs
and then we raise revenues and everybody
Republicans Democrats we you know each
one had to sacrifice a little bit here
but it was that package of what we did
that ultimately did produce a balanced
budget in a surplus so you know with
regards to the defense budget as the
secretary you know don't don't let
anybody tell you you can't find savings
in the defense budget you can on
procurement on duplication on frankly
even on for structure there are bases
that are not necessary so there are
areas we can do it but if we blind
ourselves to that if we say we're not
going to deal with this issue which is
what is happening today nothing is going
to happen and defense will continue to
go up discretionary will continue to get
screwed in the process and entitlements
will go on their track that's that's the
price we're paying and this is the
optimistic guy we've got time for one
more I think way up there's one right
there yeah I know I know there are a
bunch of them I'm just trying to see I'm
trying to be pull it way up and back
there's where yeah this have to be the
last I'm afraid I apologize I wanted to
shift the focus a little bit away from
the US and I'm going to check with you
we talked a lot about politicisation of
military share with us who you are what
school you're in there ah my name is
Devon I'm a second year MBA at the
School of Management and I wanted to ask
you if you see a similar trend happening
anywhere else in the world right now
which could potentially be a threat to
democracy in other parts of the world
well you can see it take place in some
of the NATO member countries that they
are turning more to authoritarian
leadership they are doing what is
happening in this country
attacking a the freedom of the press
doing going beyond what we do but
locking up dissidents or murdering
journalists has been taking place in
Russia and elsewhere so it's not just
the United States these are issues
taking place around the world and part
of it has to do with globalization which
we haven't really spent a lot of time
talking about and immigration the
combination and technology the three
things Tom Friedman used to write his
books about the earth is flat and by the
world becoming flat means that you can
have innovation without immigration that
people can become as educated by over
the
and taking advantage of that knowledge
learning as anyone sitting in the United
States and elsewhere so that has
produced tremendous economic
consequences globalization I think has
been good for the world at large there's
no question about it
but there are winners and there are
losers and the fact is that much of the
world has won and but in the United
States there have been some losers as a
result of that and these are the folks
who won't have a job in the future if
they have one now cannot look forward to
a better life for their family who won't
have the job skills necessary to compete
in an Information Age and frankly we
have ignored them we have not paid
attention to making sure there was a
social safety net under those people who
have been displaced Trump has
capitalized on it that's the one thing
he is zeroed in on that we as
fiduciaries have not taken into account
the consequences of what this noble idea
of spreading information and opportunity
to other parts of the world lifting up
their economies and as a result
something that we can participate in
because we sell things so it's helping
us as well by raising up the income
level of other countries but there have
been losers here and we have not paid
attention and that's why we're seeing as
being the elitist and the people who
have lost touch with those who are out
of work or certainly have the out of the
prospects that once had so it requires
us our both parties the Democrats are
trying to do this they will as they are
accustomed to doing go too far to the
left and we will continue to go far to
the right and that that middle is being
lost and so it seems to me that when we
look at presidential elections
congressional elections in the future
the people who can be slightly left of
center or slightly right or Center are
going to be the ones who will bring this
country back into governance because you
know we we play we play the political
game between the 40-yard lines if you're
in the end zones you know you can plant
your flag in the end zone
you can't make it work you can't win in
the end zone so it has to happen that
you have to come back toward the the
50-yard line and be if you're a
Republican slightly or even moderately
to the right if you're way in the end
zone it's not going to work the same
thing on the Democratic side
unfortunately right now we're both
headed for the end zones and what we've
got to do is kind of get back to the
center so let me just quickly thank
everybody and make a couple of quick
comments if I may as we close first of
all I believe the optimism is is
appropriate the challenge is real but
this really is you know this is why this
conference is about democracy this is in
your hands this is not an exaggeration
there's no hyperbole and in saying to
you it's in your hands we in in in the
last election we wound up where we are
today because we had 54.2% of people
turn out to vote in the midterm in which
we won back the house those of us were
we applies the vote was the the youth
vote went from nineteen point one
percent to thirty one percent and
everybody cheers oh my god went up to 31
percent folks that means that 69 percent
did not vote of young people who have a
greatest stake of all in terms of
climate change and and the total vote
turnout was 49 percent in the
presidential race is fifty four point
two well here's the measurement when I
ran in oh four it was sixty point three
percent turnout and when Obama ran and
was elected in 2008 it was sixty three
point five percent or so turnout get the
message I know there's a majority in
this country for doing things that are
sensible absolutely the question is can
we restore
a sense of possibility in the electoral
process and I just read you the last
paragraph of this book saving democracy
to save our democracy Americans need to
restore the basic norms that once
protected it and the two most important
norms are our tolerance and 4-barrel I
mean you've got to trust people
Americans need but we must do more than
that we must extend those norms through
a whole of a diverse society we must
make them truly inclusive America's
democratic norms at their core have
always been sound but for much of our
history they were accompanied indeed
sustained by racial exclusion now those
norms must be made to work in an age of
racial equality and unprecedented ethnic
diversity I would add to that
unprecedented inequality that has been
built into our system and then they say
a few societies in history have managed
to be both multiracial and genuinely
democratic that is our challenge it is
also our opportunity if we meet it
America will be truly exceptional so we
have really been lucky I tell you these
guys are obviously very smart they're
they're all Patriots great Patriots and
they spoke the truth today
about years of experience by which to
make the judgments they made please join
me in saying how grateful we are they
took the time
[Applause]
Thanks